well it's no secret that David Beckham
became Victoria Beckham's lover this
past July 4th the couple celebrated
their 24th wedding anniversary and they
commemorated the Milestone with some
sweet posts on Instagram sharing a
series of photos the Spice Girls star
wrote still holding hands and still
laughing with you not just at you I love
you so much David Beckham meanwhile the
former pro soccer player shared his own
throwback photo which he captioned on
this day July 4th 1999 24 years and
counting to the best wife mummy and
drinking partner most of the time happy
anniversary love you so much in response
celebrities flocked to the comments with
Eva Longoria writing happy anniversary
to my favorite couple in the world
Alyssa Milano added soap beautiful and
Josh Brolin kept it simple with Wow
after meeting in 1997 in the Manchester
United Players Lounge Victoria and David
said there I Do's two years later in
front of just 29 guests at a castle near
Dublin the couple share four children
together and looked more loved up than
ever recently attending the Glamorous
Jack moose fashion show in a rowboat at
the palace of Versace